[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation and just one
one-thousandth of ten thousand years ago
ten years ago we were working on a thing
called the Rosetta disk which was going
to collect all the languages in the
world
onto a micro etched disk that could be
read by anybody with a microscope any
time in the future they would need to be
digital and just about that time the
European Space Agency was getting ready
to launch a rocket toward a distant
comet that project was called Rosetta so
they said could we have one of your
Rosetta disks please and on the Rosetta
disk in microwatts form it was 1,500
sorry thousand languages at that point
were up to 1500 now and as of today that
disk and their rocket is now in orbit
around the comet 76p
[Applause]
[Music]
where it will remain for a very long
time a very very long time and if in
some unimaginably distant future some
entity wants to know about the languages
that were spoken on earth that long ago
they all they got to do is go to 76p and
take a microscope
a similar period of time ago I used to
work with Global Business Network and we
did occasional work for intelligence
people in Washington and one job we did
for the Department of Defense was an
interesting expansion of something we
did 30 years ago the first hackers
conference in fact there's some people
here from that John Markoff Kevin Kelly
Ryan Phelan and others we did in 83 84
we got together three generations of it
hackers that existed then this was
before net heads it's a software and
hardware and part of the discussion then
there was our hackers good guys or bad
guys and we all agreed they're good guys
and they should be aware of bad guys but
democratizing technology was going to be
a great thing the ten years ago event
that we did for Department of Defense
was called the cultures of hacking and
it was a study we did over several
months over what is what was the present
state in the like the future of
malevolent hacking and it was an
education for those of us who'd been
around back then because everything from
the skip script kiddies to the world
class mathematicians there was a whole
vast illicit ecology worldwide of
crackers of relatively demonic hackers
who were organized and sometimes
organized in relation to states and
Eastern Europe and Russia and emerging
then in China and the innocence of 30
years ago went away to their credit the
people in the defense department we did
that work for helped make that study
semi public and so people became more
aware of the kind of threats that the
Internet is ringing as well as all the
manifest benefits somebody who's been
living in the thick of that at the NSA
for a while now is a new burger please
welcome
[Applause]
good evening my name is Anne Neuberger
and I'm the principal advisor to the
director of NSA on NSA's work with a
commercial sector essentially I'm
responsible for overseeing NSA's work
with the technology sector as you can
imagine it's been a rather challenging
year or rather yes there's some humor in
that
a rather long year and I've often felt
as if the national debate was playing
itself out in my head every single day
for reasons I'll explain several months
ago earlier in the year I met Stuart
brand and a small industry event and we
had a wonderful conversation about the
ongoing debates between security and
privacy and I think we both realized
there's a fair amount of misconception
and misunderstanding on each side of the
debate of the debate and I realized that
with more open candid discussion perhaps
we could speak about some of that
misunderstanding and potentially get to
a future where we have both security and
privacy so today's presentation is the
starting point for that and I truly hope
you'll engage with me in that open
conversation I have to admit the
highlight for me of being here is
actually the question-and-answer session
trying to hurry my way through my own
remarks so I get the chance to hear your
questions engage with you and really
start that conversation but before
getting into the issues too much I'd
like to tell you a little bit about
myself my own background and why these
particular issues resonate with me in
such a such a personal way I'm a first
generation American and my family raised
me with a deep sense of appreciation for
the kindness and
see that they felt had been extended to
them the tempest-tossed the golden door
and Emma Lazarus inimitable beautiful
words my father and his parents came as
refugees from communist Hungary after
the Hungarian Revolution of 1956 and my
grandparents are all Holocaust survivors
survivors of the deportation and
concentration camps of Nazi Germany
seven of my eight great-grandparents
were killed in the largest Nazi
concentration camp Auschwitz sometime in
the spring of 1944 I'm named after a
great-grandmother who was just a bit
older than I and me and when she was
killed
so my sam'l ease background instilled in
me a deep fear of what can occur if a
government's power is turned against its
people its people or in other people
Nazi Germany was after all a
democratically elected government and
beyond that until today I see the impact
of having been raised in a communist
system on my dad hill hill marvel when
he reads a newspaper article that
criticizes a government policy and on a
visit back to Budapest 20 years ago he
still wouldn't walk past the police
station so belief in those freedoms that
are so exceptionally American is what
brought me into government several years
ago from the private sector belief in
those freedoms and a deep sense of
gratitude for the enduring welcome and
the ability to breathe free that my
family taught me to so value so given
that family background why work in the
intelligence community
you might ask and it's a fair question
just about 38 years ago when I was a
baby
my parents took their first
international trip together one that
they planned for a while they put the
money together for a while they'd really
looked forward to for a while and on
their return flight from Tel Aviv
roll to Paris and Air France flight by
way of Athens the plane was hijacked by
terrorists and taken to Entebbe Airport
in Uganda the Jewish path the non-jewish
passengers were freed and the Jewish
passengers were held hostage for a week
at gunpoint subject to constant threats
the hijackers announced that on the
following Sunday morning they'd begin
killing the passengers and on Saturday
evening under cover of darkness
an Israeli Special Forces unit flew in
and saved over a hundred hostages men
women and children a couple of the
hostages were killed the Israeli
commander of the mission Colonel
Jonathan Netanyahu also gave His life to
bring home save those hostages this is a
picture of my parents coming off the
cargo plane in Israel with the other
hostages on July 4th 1976 my dad is the
man in the middle in the back with black
glasses can't quite see my mom and he
tells me he was intent on being seen on
TV so his parents and my mom's parents
back home in America would know they
were safe so he has his hand raised
right there in the middle eager to be
caught my life would have looked very
different how that military operation
not succeeded so it gives me a
perspective on the threats of organized
terror and the role of intelligence and
counterterrorism there are threats to
the society and freedoms that I love and
the intelligence community maintains
insights into those threats I've seen
that community save lives both here in
the US and overseas warning a foreign
government for example of a planned
attack but my family background most of
all instilled in me almost parallel
belief systems on the one hand
a tremendous fear of the power of
government if turned against its people
or if left unchecked and on the other
hand a belief that sometimes only
government with its military and
intelligence can keep civilians safe
those tensions in my heart and head
shape the way I approach my work each
day and I know that they shaped the way
many of my colleagues at NSA approach
their work as well but I also believe
that these seemingly contradictory
factors can and can live in balance and
with your help I think we can define a
future where they do the long now
foundation is famous for pushing the
horizon of our thinking so here's how I
think about NSA's mission on the horizon
of your famous clock information
technology has almost unlimited promise
and potential but whereas centuries ago
it took a nation state or environmental
disaster to broadly
negatively impact a country's citizen
today I think we're reaching the point
where even individuals can use
technology to cause catastrophic harm we
can and should not limit the wonderful
potential of technology because of the
ability potentially for misuse but as a
society we need the ability to detect
deter and if necessary potentially
disable lethal threats sovereign
governments may be in a unique position
to do that and I choose the word
sovereign carefully because the
traditional definition of sovereignty is
of that social contract between a
government and governed to
protect a society from the Hans short
dark poor nasty brutish and short I
never quite get that right existence and
that's our current debate how does a
government live up to its side of that
social contract and protect against new
threats as technology evolves and how
does the government live up to that
complete social contract not violating
any element of that social contract
that's the big picture my role in the
small picture is working at the edge of
an organization that works to protect
each day while fostering innovation and
being a part and partnering helping
secure global cyber infrastructure that
underpin so much of global advancement
so what I want to talk about today is
the vision for where we're headed
probably unsurprisingly there's been a
fair amount of soul-searching at the
agency over the last number of months
over where we are today and the kind of
organization we want to be twenty to
thirty years in the future of course as
this organization particularly knows
successfully anticipating the future is
often problematic sometimes as human
beings we tend to assume things will
continue or longer a current trajectory
don't quite think about the full range
of possible scenarios so rather than
talk about where we'd like to be as an
organization in 20 to 30 years
I saw perhaps we talked about the types
of environments we may face and what
that means for us and I say as an
organization and what that means for us
as a country so to do this we'll we'll
do three things we'll talk about five
from my perspective future tensions
we'll explore as current trends continue
to develop we'll examine a few future
scenarios that could result from the
interaction of these tensions and we'll
talk about three specific hard
we'll need to resolve to navigate these
particular challenges successfully so
tensions future scenarios challenges to
resolve so what are the current tensions
I'm just going to kind of build that out
what are the current tensions that will
shape issues of security and privacy
that we face in 20 to 30 years from my
perspective and I know there are many
perspectives in the room and we'll
discuss and debate whether these are
some of them key tensions you would all
feel are the ones to think about but
from my perspective there are five key
ones the potential and risks of
interconnected cyber infrastructure
intelligence legitimacy the need to
retain technical talent the need for
personal data norms in an era of big
data and finally evolving internet
governance so let's talk about that
first one
cyber interdependencies the US and
global community are becoming ever more
dependent on digital infrastructure even
as the number and sophistication of
cyber threats or cyber attacks continue
to grow whether it's a lone wolf with a
grudge country's intent on intelligence
or economic advantage or criminal
elements intent on financial gain as
target and hundreds of other online
retailers experienced recently there are
any number of as we call them bad actors
in cyberspace and this is coupled with
the fact that the world is increasingly
interconnected as we saw tremendous
enormous amount of personal information
was stolen from target by its
interconnected air conditioning networks
the u.s. is a highly networked society
and the potential for negative impact to
that society to that open society from
malicious activity is significant so the
tension of cyber interdependencies
involves how do we balance a tremendous
promise and potential of the internet
was to ascertain
he almost equally unlimited
vulnerabilities in our cyber
infrastructure and there's a
particularly interesting angle here
because US companies are global
technology leaders governments the US
government are all customers at NSA even
our most sensitive networks run on
commercial technology so we actively
though quietly work with companies to
improve the security of products and in
some cases will even bring together a
group of companies if there's a set of
vulnerabilities that cross the stack
I've participated in some cases led
those efforts on the other hand though a
loss of trust potentially sorry by
global customers because of a potential
sense that there's two closer
relationship between any commercial
sector and any one government be the US
government or any other government has
the potential to net very negative for
our economy and the standing of our
global tech community so for NSA
specifically this first tension of cyber
interdependencies is how we manage our
mandate to secure the nation's most
sensitive networks with the need to
pursue bad actors in cyberspace so
that's that first tension the second the
intelligence legitimacy paradox
factually dovetails naturally into this
second tension one that Benjamin witness
of the Brookings Institution very
insightful he calls and I'll read this
the intelligence legitimacy paradox as
he describes it the threat environment
America faces is growing ever more
complicated and multifaceted and the
ability to meet it is growing ever more
deeply dependent on first-rate
intelligence yet at precisely the same
time many in the public have grown
deeply anxious about our intelligence
authorities and our intelligence
community is facing a profound crisis of
legitimacy over it's very authorities to
collect put another way the debate about
what powers the state needs to protect
society and the appropriate checks on
that powers on those powers
nothing new I recall early in my tenure
at NSA the first time one of our
attorneys walked me through the Fourth
Amendment for the freedom from
unreasonable search and seizure of one's
property and the history of how that was
applied over time to increasing
technologies so the telephone for
example and how Congress and the courts
determined whether the government had
the authority to search wiretap a phone
call whether that was property in this
new era so in many ways the current
debate over privacy and technology is
simply our generations continuum in this
ongoing evolution the government's had
to adjust and adapt the relationship
between technology privacy and security
over the years the noise get it right at
the first time but the key piece in our
society was that ongoing evolution so
that's that second tension the overall
legitimacy of that intelligence the
third tension I anticipate facing in the
future is when we like to talk about as
talent leverage and it revolves around
America's edge as a leader in technology
and innovation as you can imagine it's
sometimes been a challenge competing
with the private sector for technical
talent particularly when the economy is
doing well but NSA has always had a cool
mission and the ability to attract some
of the best some of the nation's best
mathematicians and computer scientists
over the past year though the
surveillance debates have painted NSA in
a rather shall we say unattractive light
and we anticipate that we'll see that in
our ability to recruit some of the
nation's best technologists but this
really goes beyond NSA so the World
Economic Forum recently ranked the US as
the 49th in the world in the quality of
math and science education after
countries such as China and Iran if
well-educated foreign engineers and
technologists build leading tech
companies overseas the US government and
our tech sector will face difficult
when how we navigate the future global
economy so the forth tension I'm
interested in the future evolves the
evolving need for personal data norms
for both private sector and government
to harness the power of the Internet of
Things while managing the very real
risks to privacy think back to the case
of target or Internet work to
air-conditioning systems
introduced a security vulnerability as a
number and variety of devices online
continues to proliferate everyday
technology will allow increasingly
ubiquitous tracking of individual
behavior by government private sector
and potentially communities of Internet
users with the right applications this
explosion of information can bring
tremendous value to society consumers
and companies but in the wrong hands or
without the right safeguards there's a
dark side to Big Data
I doubt consumers truly understand the
breadth of data collected about them
each day by the private secretary today
and how easily that data is linked and
mined to make traditional privacy
protections like an anima zation or
notice and consent largely obsolete and
further as technology continues to
evolve new frontiers may arise that we
can only speculate about today so think
about merging together digital and
genetic information there's tremendous
promise the ability to tailor drugs to
individual specific genetic mapping
making them potentially more effective
and managing side-effects better but
there's also potentially a world where
foreign enemies can create viruses that
target the specific genetic makeup of a
nation's leaders or criminal elements
cannot only steal personal information
but also personal genetic information
indeed many major industries are missing
from the security and privacy to be
including those in
Manufacturing life sciences and energy
it's a for example think about the
potential load signatures or the degree
of power different devices use can truly
help us conserve energy and very
interesting and wise ways but there's
also an interesting privacy angle in
that analyzing the load signature can
give information about a households
behavior health the health of its
inhabitants and potentially illegal
behavior although I believe growing
medical marijuana and the state is legal
so this tension involves how we harness
the power of big data to advance
technology while also keeping an eye on
the very real risks to privacy and the
last important tension has to do with
evolving internet governance whether
today's largely free a nun politicized
system of governance may slip away
resulting in uncertainty around the
global information environment
continuing debates over intelligence
surveillance has created friction with
foreign governments and technology
leaders complicating efforts to
collaborate around Internet governance
the US government firmly believes in a
free and open Internet and under US
leadership we've seen the development of
a technically oriented open
standards-based system and the challenge
is how do we ensure that that continues
so these five tensions the potential and
risks of interconnected cyber
infrastructure intelligence legitimacy
retaining our technical talent and the
need for personal data norms in an era
of big data as well as evolving Internet
governance
I think integrate into a central
question that all of us here want to
work to resolve how does a government
maintain an intelligent system
sophisticated enough to protect our
society in a complex world and how can
this be achieved while also retaining
public trust and being true to the
values and freedom
that of drawn generations of immigrants
like my family here yearning to breathe
free we can think of a range of
plausible future scenarios 20 to 30
years down the road that could resolve
from these tensions do we stand out in
my mind that I'd like to share with you
unsurprisingly the third is my preferred
choice so let's call our first scenario
intelligence debilitated in that
scenario we managed to hold our
technological age as a country improving
our STEM education and continuing to
attract the best and brightest minds
from overseas but all is not perfect in
that world at NSA we fail to develop a
new social contract with the American
public and there's ongoing distrust
between industry and a say the
intelligence community and the public
our own workforce becomes demoralized
and we face increasing difficulty in
attracting top talent our programs are
curtailed and capabilities diminished
and some might say that's a good thing
in this scenario technologies continue
to advance rapidly personal information
proliferate as people communicate and
interact in entirely new ways new ways
to aggregate manipulate mine and track
this information about of course this
technology produces tremendous value for
society but technology has also outpaced
the ability of the government to keep
pace with the workforce I just described
we probably don't even understand it and
again you might say that's a good thing
but when technology outpaces a society's
and the government in terms of that
social contract ability to understand
and modulate the hazards I think we're
all at risk
and as we talked about in that example
meanwhile terrorist groups and enemy
nations by new ways to strike at us
remotely potentially international
criminal groups come up with new and
effective ways of exploiting new data
sources to defraud or steal from
consumers and companies so the critical
question in this scenario that we need
to ask ourselves is would we be
comfortable in a world of runaway
technology and weakened intelligence
capabilities would we be safe as a
nation if the first scenario sees the US
business sector ascendant while
government's struggles the second
scenario envisions a viable scenario of
us in a slump as a nation let's call
this withering nation in this scenario
we see a backlash in the u.s. against
the unrestrained collection and use of
personal data both the private sector
and the US government face new
regulations curtail the ability to
gather and use data concurrently we
could see a global backlash against
American leadership in international
communications and technology the
internet may become more nationalized
with nations or regions developing their
own networks rules and Technology
standards we've lost our technological
edge as a country fortunately I think we
can also see a scenario where America
retains its prominence in the global
economy while being able to protect
itself responsibly from evolving threats
and being somewhat hokey we call this
scenario intelligent America in this
America we develop a new social contract
between the American public our
companies and our intelligence community
specifically NSA was time and focus the
US government and the private sector
rebuild trust between industry
government and consumers common
transparent privacy norms are
established driven
largely by rapid innovation a leadership
from the private sector so the critical
question becomes what steps do we need
to take today to envision that last
scenario from my perspective there are
three hard problems we need to resolve
in order to see that last scenario we
need to develop an effective social
contract with executive branch support
between NSA in the American public that
will allow us to build and sustain the
trust we need to face ongoing challenges
and I assure you that this problem that
this challenge is as important to NSA
and its employees as it is to our
strongest detractors on my first day at
the agency I was sworn in with an oath
that over time I felt came to reflect
the very values of the of NSA now read
that oath to you it's an abridged
version and this was it I will support
and defend the Constitution of the
United States against all enemies
foreign and domestic I will be a true
faith and allegiance to the same and
that I will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office so
help me God NSA's employees truly are
loyal dedicated public servants who
joined the energy who joined the agency
out of a desire to serve the sense over
the last year that they that we have
lost the trust of the public we served
has been tremendously devastating so
here are some initial steps we've taken
to focus and build on that social
contract first the Director of National
Intelligence and NSA are working to
share have shared more and declassified
more information than ever in its
history and it hasn't just been random
declassification it's been
intentional clot declassification of the
key programs to allow folks to
understand those programs read about
them in detail we're looking at new
methods to provide insight into
operations that still protect sensitive
sources and methods and a safe folks
always looked at themselves as the choir
professionals and the sense of walking
or talking about successes is thoroughly
countercultural on the other hand we do
need to ask ourselves how the public we
serve understands the risks and threats
particularly as the memory of 9/11 fades
and doesn't take the work done to
protect and defend against those threats
for granted this would enable our
overseers and most importantly the
public itself to make more informed
decisions that whether programs are
warranted or achieving their intent as a
third thing it's part of the effective
so as part of the work to develop a more
effective social contract NSA's been
more actively engaging with the media I
don't think an NSA or a year ago would
have come to talk here at long now what
a pleasure it is to be here that's
before the Q&A session second we've
tried to address the negative impact US
businesses have said they face in
foreign markets to preserve you as a
trust abroad the administration is
extending new privacy protections to
foreigners that were typically only
available to u.s. citizens we've begun
to develop new safeguards to limit the
duration and use of personal information
it's real I've been in myriad meetings
the measure and the government of
whether something's being taken
seriously more undoubtedly remains to be
done
US companies are global technology
leaders and technology innovation has
been the core driver of our knowledge
economy so we need to better consider
the economic risk of future intelligence
activities finally we willingly embrace
even more collection oversight NSA hired
its first ever civil liberties and
privacy officer she's terrific
and we're supporting reviews of most of
our key programs by the president's
civil liberties and oversight boards
we've begun new ways of course led by
the administration to implement the
reforms to bulk collection program so
we're really at the bulk at the bullseye
of many of the public concerns but this
cannot be a one-way street and we
definitely need your help we welcome
your input particularly this community's
input on each of these way heads and
there are different ways that you can do
that first of all get involved many of
the organizations and oversight
committees hold public hearings
I believe the president's privacy and
civil liberties oversight board held its
last public hearing July 23rd at 10:00
make your voice heard or perish the
thought come work in the government for
some period of time at least it gets a
laugh doesn't get snorts the
presidential innovation program for
example brings in people to work closely
with government folks on specific
problems for a period of time candidly
when I joined government for one year as
a White House Fellow in 2007 I didn't
think I'd stay more than a year an
equally candidly I've questioned that
decision any number of times over the
last year but on the other hand I found
the work fulfilling and the opportunity
to contribute fulfilling and I've stayed
on so consider that there are so many
ways to plug in make your voice heard
and actually get involved in in shaping
government policy in these areas
probably number two we need new tools to
unlock big data responsibly we can't
fully predict the full range of amazing
or to a certain extent frightening
technologies that could emerge over the
next several years but it's to our
collective advantage private sector and
government to define transparent
responsible norms and ensure that over
the long term we are retaining consumer
and the public's trust from the national
security perspective we have two
problems surveillance of known threats
to the US and discovery of new threats
we have tightly regimented rules for how
to gather information unknown threats
but the challenge is finding the unknown
threats those proverbial needles in the
haystack
and the challenge for us is finding
those needles without collecting and
storing necessarily that entire haystack
we're proud that we've been longtime
leaders in the area of big data and we'd
love to work with our industry big data
colleagues I'm ways to crack this on
waste willing to crack the code on
responsible data collection and
analytics the last one is one that we at
NSA have the least ability to impact and
that's we as a country to cultivate our
technical and human capital but there
are certain things that we are doing at
NSA we fund lab let's at over 300
universities to conduct basic
foundational research on the science of
security we also offer a wide range of
internship and scholarship programs at
the high school college and graduate
school levels the stokke educational
scholarship program I actually just went
to an event at that at the agency last
week offers for example minority high
school students wishing to study
computer science scholarships in that
area but this is a problem that's far
bigger than NSA it's a national
challenge so in closing we in this room
need to have honest conversations and
think big thoughts about the
relationship between civil liberties and
national security I believe we can
affect positive change I think we can
get to that intelligent America where
the interest of security society and
business are not only balanced but
optimized so my call to action for
everyone here in this audience is to get
our novel of minds focus on the
challenges we talked about today the
solutions are an obvious but this is a
group that thrives on that taking
contrarian perspectives and discovering
remarkable solutions to the most
difficult problems I truly believe we
can do this or
as generations of immigrant families
like mine always said in America
anything is possible
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks a lot
my pleasure so we're bringing up me and
Paul Sappho he finds his way up here and
like say about Paul is he has some
familiarity with this domain which you
should describe as I lost that little
cargo gave me Oh like so many of us in
Silicon Valley that we have contact from
time to time with with government
agencies I was involved with the
National Intelligence Council and the
Atlantic Council where I'm a
non-resident senior fellow in producing
global trends 2030 which in the spirit
of what you were talking about is a
publicly available document on the web
and so public in fact that the Chinese
CIA is translating it into Mandarin with
the permission of the National
Intelligence Council Kevin Kelly asked
question about this presentation how
much is this personal views and how much
it is sort of deeply vetted the NSA you
can say this now kind of stuff so I
think the broader perspective on some of
the challenges we face are certainly
held broadly across NSA but a big part
of those tensions and how they
interconnect and those trends are my
personal perspectives I think what we
were talking about here as we said
earlier you know within the agency we've
certainly done a fair amount of
soul-searching and thinking about where
we want to be and those three hard
challenges at the end the need to define
a more effective social contract that's
certainly something felt across the
agency the need and the challenge of
retaining technical talent certainly
something felt and a concern of how we
as an agency will be able to pursue our
mandate of both securing the nation's
most sensitive networks without that
ability to attract the best and
brightest of the country's minds so I
think it's probably a fair balance
although I have to think about what that
means to be fully vetted by the national
security well who else read your
for you came here you're correct correct
I said it was okay so you're kind of at
the interface I gather from your job
description between the public and
private sector in this world and are you
sort of a window in both directions are
you as you're doing today kind of
explain to the private sector look this
is what the world looks like from the
NSA are you also explaining the NSA what
the world looks like from the private
sector absolutely that's actually that's
actually exactly my rule no I
I suspect any number of folks here have
played that Bridge role between two
different cultures between two different
societies and I find that that
translation role is something I I most I
most enjoy that ability to say here are
the key concerns here are the key
perspectives in the private sector
bringing man into the agency as somebody
who also speaks agency speak and then
really taking some of the perspectives
from inside the agency and that's always
a harder challenge and translating that
to to folks outside the agency I think
ironically enough that outside in as I
mentioned earlier is actually far easier
I think perhaps surprisingly it doesn't
probably doesn't fit with the image most
folks join NSA actually spend their
careers at the agency and as a result
don't quite have the opportunity to
engage outside outside government with
the private sector so I find there's
often a deep hunger to hear for example
what's deeply felt perspective versus a
headline know and and really to
understand then to think about how that
shapes the work that we do within the
agency how that shapes the way we think
about risk the way we think about
balancing you know the the broader roles
in terms of national security the
country's power as an economic engine so
I've actually found the hunger from the
outside in makes that almost an easier
translation I think sometimes what's
more challenging is explaining the
agency's mission or explaining some of
those considerations when some big parts
of things that factor into that are hard
to talk about or they're classified so
I've actually found
a harder role but that that indeed that
serving as that bridge has been is my
role this is a generational issue is one
of the things people get the they
finally get their clearance and they're
behind the secrecy wall and typically
once you're in the intelligence world
you stay in the intelligence world for
obvious reasons you you've been vetted
you're working and you know the stuff
are people getting problematically older
within these organizations because
typically in companies it's going the
other way the younger and younger people
especially in tech companies rule so is
this a young turks and old farts
interface that we're talking about here
or what
not quite geeks and geezers geeks and
geezers yeah there are some geezer geeks
it's true but I think it's folks here
who interacted was either the military
or government for that matter no they
are more hierarchical societies and
average private sector particularly the
technology sector right the heavy as
part of DoD I mean this is you have what
how many people your report do one yeah
exactly
I'm trying to make a point in any event
so it is far more shall we say
hierarchical I think that being said the
key movers and shakers are of course the
folks who are closest to technology the
folks who are most current increasingly
at NSA I'm a good example there are
younger folks coming in and being put in
positions of responsibility which is
exciting that's also a great way for us
to attract and retain talent from
outside so I think that folks understand
that for an agency to be innovative and
on the forward edge of technology
generally you need folks who are not as
wedded to the way we may have done
something period of time ago but to find
that balance between experience and new
ideas there's really the challenge of
every organization but particularly one
that's very sensitive to risk and works
in a very in a very sensitive area yeah
well especially because companies
allowed to go out of business and you
guys aren't which is a good thought
we've thought about that over the last
year as well
Francis posed this question when Russia
invaded Ukraine it seemed to take us by
surprise and here's his question have
Snowden's revelations damaged our
ability to anticipate sudden moves by
rivals and adversity adversaries now
you're welcome to answer the Snowden
part but what I really like you to do is
talk a little bit about that nothing
very knotty problem of surprise and
warning and I recall when the Berlin
Wall fell everybody was surprised there
was an interview and the James Baker
said caught me by surprise
Lawrence Eagleburger said I had no idea
it was happening George Shultz said yeah
I was completely surprised and Richard
pipes a a Russian specialist was also
surprised and it seems that if we go
back through the last couple of decades
surprise is the norm in intelligence and
is that ratio changing and of course
there's Snowden factored into this so
we'll talk about each of those two
questions for a moment so I'll quote
some of the things the director of NSA
has said about that first question I
think the first question he the way he
spoke to the the impact of the of what
we call inside the media leaks really is
that it is hard to anticipate today you
know what that impact will be that's a
long term impact yes have we seen
evidence that certain what we call
intelligence in areas of interests
people or groups that the intelligence
community was monitored have we seen
them talk about changing the way they
communicate because of the Snowden leaks
absolutely are we concerned that when
that change happens we no longer have
the ability to have insights into what
they do absolutely so from that
perspective yes we have seen an impact
but that assessment is longer-term and
the final point he's made is it will
always be hard to define between what
are natural changes in technology for
example a certain organization deciding
to upgrade their networks and the
intelligence community potential
Liuzza's inside as a result from a
change that's made because of having
read a particular media revelation so
that's kind of the way that we've talked
about that first question you asked and
I think in terms of the second question
now one of the we we talked about it
here a bit you know one of the hardest
pieces in terms of predicting the future
which is the question you're asking is
understanding the different key trends
and tensions occurring and which ones
will relate and interrelate and that's
really a challenge that I think is faced
in the private sector in terms of
understanding you know which are the
technologies that will succeed which are
the best to make and certainly very much
in government one of our hopes is that
with the proliferation of data sources
we'll be able to actually pull together
interesting data sources for example a
population sentiment what folks say
between themselves understand now
perhaps in a way that was harder too
prior to that perhaps in the past you
only could look at public media now you
have the ability to understand that at a
much more granular level but pulling
those different trends intentions
together and having a sense of where
that will result is an ongoing challenge
and it's something that we continue to
think about let me just follow up on
that a little bit because it seems like
the intelligence community have always
been data optimists that if we just had
more data and and we know after every
crisis its well if if there had been
more data we connect the dots and you
know there's a classic example like I
think of 9/11 but this was said by the
Church Committee in 1975 it's become
commonplace to translate criticism of
the intelligence results into demands
for in large data collection does data's
more data really lead to more insight I
think one of the well that's an
interesting question that's a private
sector of big data that may be changing
with data mining Silicon Valley we all
live in it I mean and with big data is a
friend likes to say perhaps the data
haystack that the intelligence community
has created is
grown too big to ever find the needle in
I think one of the reasons that we
talked about our desire to work with big
data peers on analytics is because we
certainly feel that we can glean far
more value from the data we have and
potentially collect less data if we have
a deeper understanding of how to better
bring that together to develop new
insights as I mentioned you know that
one of the hardest challenges we have is
the discovery of new threats once you're
aware that a certain individual is
planning something it's a degree of
understanding the technology
understanding the way they communicate
but the challenge of figuring out what
we call our unknown unknowns is one that
that's a scary thought we use thank you
the wrong guy advertised it that's right
thanks Val Ewell appreciate that forget
sometimes I'm on the west coast but that
ability to really think about how
analytics help us achieve the mission
while potentially managing that
collection differently is really the
goal and it's really the reason we'd
love to build that partnership so
Elliott as specific questions secure
information and privacy need to be
balanced please give us an example of
when you feel the NSA worked at its best
in this balanced regard I would love it
if for your specific you think of an
interesting example I can actually talk
about balancing secure information and
privacy this is no problem you're not
being recorded so that will be highly
ironic
you know I have to admit so I got here
you know about an hour earlier Stewart
and I were talking and very kind Andrew
here put on my mic and I'm thinking hmm
this is rather interesting I wonder if
it's turned on how will I know in any of
it actually everybody in the rooms
wearing a wire as well see and you know
when we talked about that earlier so I
folks may not have picked up from my
accent I'm originally from Brooklyn so
when you mentioned that earlier I kind
of gulped and said really reeling a wire
okay if you're not from Brooklyn maybe
that doesn't resonate but okay in any
event so with regard to the security and
privacy I think I'll talk about one
effort I'm not going to get really
specific yes that's hard but in one case
with an NSA we had insights about a
potential threat because of a class of
vulnerabilities a class of technology
vulnerabilities and we brought together
you know a small group of companies and
kind of sat down and said we're gonna
share this to share this intelligence
with you and help us understand how
broad is the threat we actually don't
know how vulnerable key systems are to
this key systems we have in the
government key systems across critical
infrastructure and the folks said you
know we actually don't know either I'll
take a look and everybody went back and
we established a study group that
actually studied that area and then
quietly over the next few months we all
came together we all brought some of our
key experts and work together it was a
set of ulnar abilities they actually
crossed chipsets operating systems etc
and we actually worked together and
defined certain standards and worked
closely and then the companies work to
quietly implement those and raise the
bar of security in their products so
that's an example where it's not
necessarily the privacy of individuals
was the privacy of the companies
involved that really wanted the ability
to focus on class of vulnerabilities it
was in nobody's interest for that's we
talked about publicly from an NSA
perspective clearly there were sensitive
sources and methods from a company
perspective there was a
companies desire to focus on those
vulnerabilities and I think the key
piece there that it's important to
highlight is the one we talked about
earlier which is that NSA specifically
in the broader US government uses
commercial technologies across all of
our systems so we do actively work to
raise the bar of that security to
partner on that that's something we do
quietly because clearly it's it's
probably no one's interests at least
from a broader perspective but it's
certainly something that we try to
balance in that way I'll as you asked me
further questions I'll try to think of
more specific examples that occurs me
the company issue mostly talking about
our American companies totally or mostly
or what pretty much you know for example
our information assurance Directorate
defines some standards that non-us
companies for example mobility stances
have worked to me in order to meet
various government procurements so
that's one tool we use to kind of raise
certain standards because to a certain
extent the Department of Defense does
have a large IT budget although we're
often told we no longer matter in terms
of consumer consumer acquisition really
driving it but to the extent we can we
do work to define those standards and
then any company that wants to meet them
of course we welcome that well so you
talk about about the US Constitution and
there's there's a national role there's
a national government a lot of these
issues go way outside national they're
it's the whole internet in the sense
that you're trying to help secure its
come these that are working with things
way outside the US there's probably
things that you would like to have not
only safe for in a way for us but even
in a sense for adversaries the example
of that being back in the day when I
think Reagan before him Eisenhower is
pushing for open skies that what
satellites found should be available to
all and there was a lot of pushback on
that as you may well remember but it
turned out that that kind of data being
available from sand
lights helped everybody's defense and
didn't give that much help to
everybody's offense and so then Clinton
released it so that our GPS has told us
exactly where we were instead of
generally where we were and so there was
a sort of nationally enabled and then
encouraged improvement of data that
everybody could have is any of that rare
relation to what you guys are having to
deal with now it does it does in terms
of it doesn't it doesn't from an NSA
perspective it does in terms of efforts
to share vulnerabilities efforts to
think about so here's perhaps a better
way to put it you know prior to really
in many ways September 11th was a
turning point for the intelligence
community because prior to that quite
candidly most of our areas of foreign
intelligence interests were foreign
governments and foreign governments
typically used their own national
technology sometimes their own
indigenous encryption so that was a
particular set of foreign intelligence
needs after September 11th there really
was an increase in some key missions
counterterrorism counter-proliferation
counter-narcotics but most importantly
you had transnational actors who use
commercial technologies for all the
reasons we love it it's ubiquitous it's
free it's good so for the first time you
we really were faced with a foreign
intelligence target using the same
technologies in many cases NSA was so
that balance of how do you maximize the
security of the technologies you're
using while also maintaining the ability
to have insights and to foreign
intelligence targets became the central
challenge and the central balance and
that's been something that a lot of
folks think about very carefully
that's that tension I talked about
earlier each and every day
and that really was the key turning
point to a certain extent the removal of
controls on the export of encryption and
the late 90s was a piece of that but it
really was the growth of suddenly a
transnational foreign intelligence need
that really used the same web platforms
that we all use the same technologies
that we all use oh my this is a sign of
love I'm feeling it we judge a lot about
our speakers by the quantity and quality
of questions I know Jim and Kelly yes
since he was here we just saw him what's
the best mechanism for an Intelligence
Agency to prevent themselves from using
national security secrecy to cover up
embarrassments is there something better
than whistleblowers there's the Freedom
of Information Act
walkest laughter I don't know you may
laugh inside the agency the numbers
skyrocketed and there's more and more
folks who are just working pulling few
Information Act requests and data for
that so see how that's working in ways
that you think that effective so the
question you asked me whether there are
mechanisms mm-hmm
and I think so I look at you know
sometimes I come to work I talked about
that tension and I think of myself as
the US citizen and I kind of divorced my
mind from my my day-to-day job and I say
what would I think about this just as a
routine person and I think certainly
there are I think the protections built
in in terms of the ability to ask a
question you know it I can see where
from the perspective of the technology
sector
perhaps the amount of time it takes or
the sense that things get redacted makes
the freedom Information Act seem like
probably an unwieldy or useless tool
again I'm looking at it from the angle
of inside the agency where I see the
careful thought that goes into each one
to say what could be shared or can't be
shared
what would potentially impact sensitive
sources and methods and what doesn't and
real work goes into it I've seen it for
just those few that that that have been
related to that I've worked on so I
think I guess again in that bridge role
I can appreciate the perspective that
it's just humorous and doesn't achieve
very much but from inside the agency I
see that real works done to try to you
really think about what can be
declassified what can be shared to be
responsive so I think going back to the
question about what other tools are
available you know I think you know I
think some of the things we talked about
earlier in terms of there's a lot of
oversight
you know attending some of those
oversight panels looking at the
opportunity to serve on a civil
liberties or oversight board
posing questions there's any number of
policy discussions asking policy makers
those kinds of questions I think there
are any number of paths I see the number
of tough questions and increasingly I
think we can do more
on the NSA side coming to events like
this it's certainly you know it's a
pleasure to be here it's certainly not
easy for folks who are trained in an
environment where you know need to know
you don't talk about certain things
there there are very significant
controls inside and in fact those have
been increased to make sure that if
there isn't a need for somebody to know
balance by the need for sharing and the
need to bring teams together we get that
balance right but I think by shall we
say folks within the intelligence
community making a point to try to come
out talk about programs so declassify
when possible and in fact now they've
been increasing discussion of saying
when we're creating a new policy can we
create an unclassified version that was
part of a discussion like that just last
week so I think it's that coming from
both sides things the the public perhaps
taking the time to understand things at
a level of detail below the headline and
then from the intelligence community
taking the time to come to discussions
to do our part within to ensure that
there are potentially unclassified
versions of policies you know I'll give
a good example the congressional
legislation underpinning all of NSA's
programs so we talked about the section
215 be our FISA for example just a
program that was collecting metadata and
US persons phone calls those were all
sorry authorized by Congress and then
reauthorized repeatedly those were all
on the record those were easy for folks
to take the time to to look at and
review and they were as I said
continuously reauthorized so I think
it's it's that balance sometimes there's
a lot of information out there but you
know it may not necessarily be in a in a
way that's easy to comprehend
you know quite candidly sometimes when I
look at all the information we
Declassified and wading through it you
know so there's good more there's
further work we can do in the IC to give
to index it to add to add context to it
etc but I do think there is a fair
amount of information out there for
folks who take the time to read study to
ask questions certainly complex it's
I'll be the first to say sometimes it's
certainly it's a fair amount of
intelligence ease this is
very hopeful indicator in our last
elections here in California 18 percent
of the electorate voted so very hopeful
that we will have engaged citizens
looking deeply into folks can raise
their hand
we've got hey I get to ask tough
questions to once in a while absolutely
um we have a whole bunch of Snowden
questions that you can't possibly answer
so that's so I'm sort of synthesised
a couple and I and and and here's the
question what were the positive aspects
of the Snowden revelations if you look
at I mean there is no win so ill that it
does not blow some good what is the
silver lining to this this cloud for the
NSA so again I I I'll reference
something the director of NSA talked
about you know fundamentally NSA in the
broader intelligence community's role is
protecting and defending the United
States fundamentally serving the
American public and as technology
evolves as knowledge about threats and
risk evolved we are a decade after 9/11
sometimes there isn't a natural way for
that discourse for that societal
contract to continue to get updated some
from the perspective of understanding as
a society where folks thoughts are a
decade after 9/11 how that ongoing
harmony of security and privacy evolved
I think has been very helpful for for
many folks to see and understand and I'm
hopeful some well as we talked about in
terms of the the Fourth Amendment and
how telephone technology how that
evolved over time it's actually
fascinating if you look at the evolution
of that between the courts and Congress
over time I think that that evolution
requires an educated public eye requires
a intelligence community that engages so
I think we're we're in a healthy place
from that perspective
so Gary greener has a great follow-on
question to your observations he
observes privacy is legally an
implied right the fourth fifth and tenth
amendments should it be an explicit
right and if so how should it be
architected that's an interesting
question
you know I think that does this you know
I think looking at the Fourth
Amendment's specifically search and
seizure property right it was initially
defined as physical property and in fact
there was a discriminant which mean
Congress on the course as that became
ones digital property you know I think
that the key elements of privacy our
homes our communications are really
protected implicitly and that we haven't
at least from my perspective I think
we've seen those constitutional rights
upheld and of all throughout our history
so at least from my personal perspective
and now I speak from my personal
perspective to Stewart's earlier point
no I I think that those protections and
those freedoms are implicit and have
served the original framers intent that
you'd have to ask a constitutional
attorney questions then most Dale and
Michael both have questions related to
RSA random number generator used dance
version of the question do you consider
the NSA's role in weakening the RSA
random number generator to be a
violation of the NSA existing social
contract how do you think about its
exploit ability by criminal elements so
explain what we're talking about here so
first and above all I am we made a
decision just about a year ago that NSA
couldn't talk about individual programs
because of the concern that you know
we'd get out there and we'd say X is not
true where Y is not true and then when
something had elements of truth you know
we'd have a hard time it'd be clear from
the fact that we didn't say anything
that there was an issue there so I
cannot talk about specific efforts as a
result I think at a high level yeah
right at a high level generically and if
folks need I can explain what that issue
is
or what that question is but I think at
a high level there's three pieces the
first is that as I mentioned a couple of
times
NSA the US government uses commercial
technology across all of our systems we
use the encryption and standards that we
advocate for and we advocate for the
encryption and standards that we use so
as an extension of that and again I
cannot speak to individual efforts or or
or concerns but as an extension of that
we've worked to raise the level of
security in that technology because we
understand the vulnerabilities and we
understand the way nation-state actors
specifically would be targeting those
vulnerabilities and I apologize this is
not a particular satisfying answer but
that's pretty much given the kind of
clear guidance we've had we cannot talk
about specific programs that's pretty
much as far as as I can go won't you say
about the I don't know the trends and
threats quantity quality sources or the
general thing which I mean companies are
well aware that they're getting
different kinds of attacks from
different sources and different loads
and so presumably this is not something
especially NSA the you would have to
reveal but I think people also don't
know what the private companies are
facing so what's the threat environment
like in the house is changing I think
that's such a terrific question really
particularly in the area of cyber and
vulnerabilities and cyber infrastructure
and I think we see three different
categories of threats and certainly the
prior director of NSA general Sanders
talked about it I think is the largest
theft of property in history I think we
see those three levels first and above
all we see to a certain extent
nation state government for either
competitive advantage or for
intelligence advantage but in terms of
the private sector for competitive
advantage there is significant amounts
of research and technology that are
certainly being targeted by either other
guard
for for their benefit for the economic
growth I think from the perspective of
financial elements criminal elements
intent on financial gain that's where
you see specifically online retailers
facing those stress actually had an
interesting just today I used my credit
card checking into the hotel and it was
denied and I had an email saying you
know that my credit card information you
know I shouldn't use it etc they need to
get a new car so it was particularly
interesting for me I just experienced
that today but in any event so I think
that there is those sets both for
criminal intent and for nation-states
they can't even protect your credit card
I am NOT going to answer that question
there's some Nigerians will be very
happy in any event so and we see an
increasing trend and I think one of the
things that we are seeing is a greater
awareness by companies of that trend and
really a growth in the security market
which we're happy about because from
NSA's perspective increased security
across US companies across really
globally as something we fully support
so I think we're there's this excitement
and the sense that finally you know some
of the boring security recommendations
or best practices at various information
assurance groups have been recommending
for years now I actually have a price
tag attached in terms of folks actually
seeing because of course many security
improvements are a cost so there's got
to be that balance particularly in the
private sector where there's a and this
is a joke where there's a sensitivity to
cost unlike the government
so big a threat to everything is me and
everybody else being careless with our
passwords
I think you've we've seen that in many
ways of course passwords are still
there's been much talk about the death
of passwords but passwords are still the
core way we authenticate and still the
core way we protect data so obviously
and most certainly being careless about
passwords is something that until we get
beyond passwords to new technologies
this you know there's someone we'd love
to see one of the one of those security
practices that NSA's advocated for for a
long time has been tying hardware and
software so really building Hardware
roots of trusts into mobile devices into
all devices where you can store key
elements cryptographic elements that
then can authenticate all the way up
from hardware to software in any way
that can then authenticate uniquely so
that's one of the areas that we've
encouraged for quite some time that we
would then hope you could then tie to
various other personal identifying
information so if the level of security
sort of from the public for the public
went up how much more secure does the
whole environment get is that
improvement or huge so there's different
in terms of as a society so I think from
the government perspective we often
focus on threats to critical
infrastructure threats to control system
so that's somewhat different technology
they often benefited from that old
security by obscurity but I think in
terms of threats to consumers threats to
banking threats to individuals personal
information that's certainly something
where from a government perspective the
more careful folks are the more folks
raise the bar the more technologies make
it easier to actually use security and
that's been one you know slightly well
fully positive I'm trying to be slightly
because it's because of the earlier
question that's one certainly positive
impact of some of the Snowden
revelations a sense of a growth in
privacy related technologies certain
growth so from that perspective I think
that the greater public focus on that is
something we would consider very very
positive so if people are protecting
themselves from NSA they'll actually
improve the overall security system I
wouldn't put it quite like that but the
end goal
is something we would support yes Stuart
so there's there's a sub current about
openness in the whole conversation and
we've certainly seen in business world
where companies have done very radical
open steps and famously there's one
company called core that released its
most secure information about a
particular mining property and had a
competition to see who could figure out
where the gold was on this property and
this was pure heresy to release that
data now I realize the NSA operates
under certain constraints but part of
your problem is you're not very open but
it's only what twenty years ago that you
give out your street address is there
some sort of transformation that is is
there is there some some role that open
systems thinking can play in all this in
terms of public engagement and getting
better data one of our vocals bill joy
famously observed no matter how good
your company is all the smart people
don't work for you absolutely
so NSA is actually really tried to work
more with the open-source community so
you may know for example the original
NSA released or was a part of SELinux in
2000 accumulate which was built on
Google's BigTable was something that was
done from the 2008 I believe and then
released fully in 2011 I have to check
my dates on that and then continuing
contributions to open source various
other technologies beyond that so there
actually is a greater focus for example
some of the cell based security work
that was done was really NSA
contributions to open source so there's
a great deal more focus now on making
contributions in that area and lots of
folks are really proud about that I
don't have all the details but I know
those three specific efforts and I
believe there are more beyond that so if
just to follow on in the same spirit of
transformation my sense that as a
citizen observing that the Snowden
event is kind of a missed opportunity
for transformation inside the
intelligence community that previous
crises have led to deep transformations
you talked about 9/11 moving away from
the bias of nation-state actors to to
non nation-states and a couple of
questions here they've handout at Fred's
example Kevin Kelly session the NSA play
a role in devising the new rules for
cyber work if I think of a sweep of the
intelligence community over the last
couple of decades there's always been
the tension between analysis and policy
formulation and we've had a pretty
strict history in this country that
analysis was done by one agency policy
formulation done by another does that
still make sense in this day of big data
in the light should NSA be doing policy
from my perspective and again this is a
broader question but the executive
branch defines policy defines those
programs and then the intelligence
community then executes them and I think
that that's been one of the key items
that folks within NSA I have a analysis
and you hand it off to the agencies that
the gun toters or the FBI or whoever
Alice's home actual policy formulation
so I was thinking of and let's go back
just to be sure I understand your
question I was thinking of policy
formulation more in terms of the way
Congress or the executive branch define
and say you know here's the way you were
permitted to do collection your as an
agency you do the analysis that
identifies the threat you hand that off
to somebody else to come up with the
policy of dealing with the threat ah ha
and the question again just so I follow
should that separation continue so
that's an interesting question
there's a number of different ways to
address that and I think to Stuart's
earlier point asked me a few other
questions because I think no speaking
very honestly it's an area that we've
talked about inside and explored I'm not
really clear on on what my boundaries
are to talk about there so rather than
air I'd rather okay we have lots of
other the relationships between agencies
between for various missions is
something that that's fair
take a step back on that for now a great
issue because I was going to ask you
should NSA stop being both civilian and
military and become civilian and that's
probably not the recent director figured
that out
he just went civilian turned out to be
very problem that was a joke
Oh dad yep she doesn't work we mostly
talk about cyber stuff and but terrorism
is you know still the main event in many
respects in terms of both perceived
threat in in another dimension actual
threat I imagine so I asked about the
sort of general threat domain in terms
of cyber what's the your perception of
the general threat domain and trends in
terms of terrorism so again you know I
think you've seen any number of
administration officials and various
intelligence officials talk about that
the concerns that you know one of the
that we have somewhat a fear about
Western trained Western individuals
going to various areas of unrest in the
Middle East
getting training and weapons and coming
back I think we saw a Florida man
recently you may have seen the Florida
man travel to Syria gone training came
back home and then traveled back and
blew himself up in a suicide attack in
Syria and that's I think the biggest
fear of the intelligence community today
you know Westerners US persons have a
very heavy protections under the
Constitution clearly they're not
monitored
without a really good without a really
good sense that somebody is certainly
doing something of real concern so that
sense of folks crossing borders equipped
with a Western or a US passport and then
equipped with potential training on
weapons is certainly something that's a
big area of concern I think generally
history has shown us in many cases that
lawless areas breed folks who are
trained folks who are equipped with
weapons and certainly over the last
number of years has been an increase in
the number of area lawless areas areas
of conflict around the world so I think
there's certainly a heightened concern
about the potential for those kinds of
activities of 13 years now since 9/11 we
haven't had that kind of attack since
then who do we thank for that I think we
certainly thank the hard work of the
intelligence agencies of the US and
allies overseas I think the one of the
hardest challenges in the social
contract between a public and
intelligence community and the military
is that by definition the work of the
intelligence come organizations has to
be done in the shadows and certainly you
know it's I talked about the quiet
professionals earlier for folks who who
ever come have a visit to the National
Security Agency and I believe it's the
same and other intelligence agencies CIA
etc so you walk in and then you kind of
take a right and then right in front of
you is a black granite wall and it says
on top they served in silence and it has
the names mostly military of individuals
who lost their lives as cryptologist or
as various intelligence professionals
over the years I can say that in the
five years I've been at NSA I've gone to
five six ceremonies where new names were
engraved on the wall you have the family
members come but they really that's not
talked about you know how they lost
their lives what was done and I think
you know achieving that balance how to
help the public understand what's being
done so that they can make fair
judgments about whether these efforts
are warranted whether they're achieving
the intent it's certainly something that
thinking about how as an intelligence
community we share some of the work
that's being done while a protecting
sources and methods and be also
remaining those quiet professionals I
think is really it's really a central
challenge it's something that folks
there's a certain internal pride when
you know an attack is thwarted or some
information about a potential plan is
shared with a shared with a with a
foreign government and certainly is not
something that is is talked about or
certainly the encouragement of talking
about that is not something that's done
for very very good reasons you certainly
don't want folks jockeying for four
credits so I think but on the other hand
how does the public understand what's
being done so I think that balance and
creative ideas of how to achieve that
balance from my perspective from folks
coming in so from the intelligence
community going to the outside
seeing how communication is done folks
from the outside coming into government
understanding the need to protect
various sources but also the need to
communicate I think that's a prime
example of we're better sharing of
techniques of understanding happens by
people moving between those communities
how much of the quiet secret environment
is a appropriate left over from the Cold
War where there was a symmetrical
challenge basically the Soviet Union in
the u.s. we're standing off the rest of
world was trying to stay out of the
client wars and the much more asymmetric
threat environment now our you know
Russia's a national problem as well but
nothing like what it was and is should
the nature of how secrecy works within
the government changing this asymmetric
environment or just a slightly retune
the way we did in the Cold War
so we've certainly seen the
administration President Obama make
commitments to say we're going to push
for more transparency we're going to
push for more openness and that's making
its way through government more
something of saying the American public
who served is pressing for more
transparency so that defines overall the
approach there so and you're certainly
seeing that across government in in any
number of ways and I think that it's
appropriate I think fundamentally if you
know somebody made a comment to me they
said you know to a certain extent
privacy is dead and then if they ask to
think about what's the state of its own
privacy and I think that that tension
pushing for that balance of in a
democracy how do public's how to
citizens maintain insights and the work
that's done for their behalf in a way
that allows the public who is served by
it to make judgment calls that's the
core tension and I think that you know
its rightful that it's that tension
because that's how we'll get to the
right place so I certainly think from an
administration perspective there's a
pressed for more transparency and we're
seeing it as I talked about in the far
greater declassification we're seeing
that in open hearings and privacy and
civil liberties reports and Indy classic
unclassified reports that are being
issued about programs that were not even
acknowledged you know some time ago
notification passive or active you just
sort of quietly let something now be
visible or you might be interested in
this which is no longer a secret
I believe the Director of National
Intelligence has I believe they post I'm
actually they do post on their website
and in some cases you know they'll get
out their release media releases I don't
know if the DNI tweets I know CIA does
but it's certainly if you visit DNI site
there's they're all listed there the
various C classifications they're sorted
can spend some time on the site there's
also various policy think tanks that
have kind of taken the information and
put it into better context so it's
easier to follow and understand
I think Brookings Institute for example
I talked about been witnessed earlier
he's done phenomenal work really pulling
that together the different programs the
timeline of certain programs a legal
structure
I found the tremendously helpful you
know taking a look at that and and
putting context around what was
Declassified to better understand that
so I think that I would actually
encourage both the DNI site but also
some various policy think tanks that
have given it context put it into
history and made it much more consumable
Bush here you are I mean Thank You Anne
for coming out of the shadows
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you